bonjour
est-ce que vous m'entendez bien
oui
ok merci vincent d'avoir un point de vue
oui très bien parfait vous mais parfait
super on va pouvoir commencer alors
bonjour je suis sans un char de la
chambre de métiers l'artisanat de
l'essonne je m'occupe de la
communication
bienvenue et merci de participer à cette
quatrième édition de ma journée
découverte des métiers de l'artisanat
organisé par la chambre de métiers et
d'artisanat de l'essonne en partenariat
avec la faculté des métiers de l'essonne
qui se trouve à il rit le cfa du
bâtiment qui se trouve à brétigny sur
orge et les apprentis d'auteuil à
marcoussis les cinq web conférence que
nous proposons aujourd'hui dans le cadre
de la semaine nationale de
l'apprentissage sont consacrés à
l'orientation des jeunes vers des
métiers du goût de l'automobile de la
fleuristerie du bâtiment et de la beauté
donc nous avons déjà eu de web
conférence ce matin l'une à 9h30 et
l'autre à 10h30 et donc c'est notre
troisième conférence sur ce sujet là
avant de commencer je voudrais vous
livrer quelques informations sur le
secteur de l'artisanat et sur
l'apprentissage qui attire de plus en
plus de jeunes et d'adultes en
reconversion
l'artisanat c'est 1,3 100 millions
d'entreprises en france
c'est la première entreprise de france
c'est son slogan en ile de france on
compte deux cent cinquante mille
entreprises artisanales et en essonne
trente et un mille entreprises
artisanales
plus d'un tiers des apprentis sont
formés par des dirigeants d'entreprises
artisanales c'est un énorme pourcentage
ce qui fait que l'apprentissage fait
quand même énormément partie de l'adn de
l'apprentissage
de la madeleine de l'artisanat pardon
confondre les deux il faut savoir que la
formation en apprentissage offre de très
belles perspectives d'avenir soit pour
être salarié en entreprise
80 % des apprentis
qui trouve un job à temps
en cdi pardon à l'issue de leur
formation dont 80% soit pour être
entrepreneur 41% des actuels dirigeants
d'entreprises artisanales ont suivi un
cursus en apprentissage
voilà de quoi alimenter vos discussions
et surtout nous espérons que cette
journée suscitera des vocations chez
vous
qui est derrière cet écran place
maintenant à la présentation
de la filière des métiers du goût avec
autour de la table
j'accueille
stéphanie du bion
stéphanie du bion tué chargé de
développement sur la filière du goût à
la faculté des métiers
j'accueille nicolas barbares ans qui est
formateur en pâtisserie à la faculté des
métiers
débris
j'accueille également inès qui est
apprenti ans est happé et cuisine et
alexis qui apprentis en btm faty ce
rythme voilà
écouté
pendant sept heures de votre conférence
nous allons vous livrer beaucoup
d'informations je vous invite à poser
toutes les questions sur le chat qui est
à votre disposition
n'hésitez pas quel que soit votre
question nous y répondrons enfin de
webinaires nous consacrerons 15 à 20
minutes à la fin de cette conférence
pour répondre à toutes les questions
qu'ils se reposaient sur le tchat je
voulais juste vous dire que ce cette
webconférence est enregistrée et elle
sera diffusée en replay sur tous nos
médias prochainement voilà je laisse la
place à stefani qui va nous faire une
présentation
de ce qu'est l'apprentissage pour
commencer
merci alors manqueront pas bonjour donc
âge vous présenter ce qu'est exactement
l'apprentissage donc peut-être que ça
comment trouver le savent mais déjà la
patte et des médias écrits nous avons 80
des formations régulières base et c'est
bien à ma fille tout ce qui est ça
représente toutes les formations
des tertiaires bon donc posté
industrielle est restée un peu tout et
surtout nos filières artisanales en
sachant qu'il ya des métiers du goût les
soins de beauté également autorisé
représente surtout avec les goûts à la
fête des métiers c'est non seulement des
formations mais plein de l'apprentissage
on a beaucoup beaucoup d'entreprises
partenaires que ce soit la petite
entreprise du point ce que j'ose dire
comme la grosse entreprise
qui pète aussi connu nationalement au
mondialement alors l'apprentissage
qu'est ce que c'est également comme vous
êtes j'espérais après l'apprentissage en
l'apprentissage également jab à la clé
c'est à dire que le contrat
d'apprentissage est un contrat aidé qui
est orienté paquet qui est orienté pour
les jeunes de 15 à 29 ans révolus à
savoir vous pouvez faire l'apprentissage
ou de la voix de 29 ans si vous êtes
dans une situation particulière dans le
handicap quoi bon jouer un changement
d'emploi femmes apprécient très
particulier donc qu'est-ce que le
contrat d'apprentissage donc c'est ainsi
d'aider de date à date c'est à dire
qu'il y avait une date de fin qui
doivent couvrir toute la période de
formation donc j'avais aussi bien des
cours entre des cours au cfam période de
présence en entreprise d'où
l'apprentissage essayer une formation en
alternance et donc l'alternance
l'apprentissage m'arrive entre 6 mois et
3 ans mais ça après tout des points du
cursus que vous avez choisi donc quand
je disais que c'est un viol à la clé
disons que l'apprentissage un des plus
beau tremplin pour apprendre un métier
surtout dans les métiers d'artisanat ou
vraiment n'apprenez et la pratique ça
c'est sûr mais aussi la théorie et plus
vite vous aller pratiquer plus vite vous
ne deviendrez des bonbons
professionnelle parce que vous aurez
plus
l'appétence et vous saurez plus
pratiquer vos métiers également
l'apprentissage en seulement une
formation mais ça permet aussi 80% de
l'auto défense qui fut
d'abord un enfant bien souvent la paz
atlantique nous avons conscience passe
très bien je suis dans leur entreprise
d'accueil d'apprendre pendentif soit il
trouve un métier assez facilement
sachant que les métiers du goût saartjie
passe un facteur travail chez clients
sachant c'est un métier qui s'exporte à
l'étranger on a beaucoup de jeunes qui
sont à l'étranger aux états unis en
australie en angleterre vraiment c'est
un métier très facile à ces 4èmes
inconnue est surtout reconnu par
l'unesco c'est vraiment très bon surtout
ce qui est question de me française
quelle qu'elle soit aussi bien la
boulangerie et pâtisserie cuisine
également donc c'est une formation donc
lac du causse d'excusés avec un emploi à
la clé
est aussi une chose très importante
qu'il ne faut pas oublier c'est que qui
dit travail du salaire donc là vous
voyez que par exemple si vous débutez
l'apprentissage que vous êtes miller
c'est vraiment une année d'apprentissage
vous avez démarré à 27% disent non au
fur et à mesure du temps vous allez
augmenter en salaire mais attention à
cette crise d'erreur binerie le base
accueille chacun particuliers par
exemple avril et si nous avons un
lexique un des thèmes qu'il sera pas
payée parce que c'est différent dans ce
cas ça c'est la base et sachez que plus
vous allez augmenter en âge et
informations et mieux vous serez pays
basque habiller un peu plus
de plus
que
[Musique]
les questions après ça
bonjour il faut savoir que comme le ce
replay et est enregistrée vous
retrouverez toutes ces informations ne
regarderont plus précisément s'il a
besoin de de faire un point sur le
pourcentage de rémunération ou autres ou
alors d'appeler les cfa en particulier
là je propose qu'on qu'on passe aux
sondages donc vous vous avez vu que nous
avons posé une question sur le chat et
la question est combien
d'apprentis trouve un cdi après leurs
études
normalement vous devriez pouvoir y
répondre est ce que c'est 20 % est-ce
que c'est 80 % ou est-ce que ces
cinquante et un pour cent pour cent ont
des réponses c'est bravo un grand oui
c'est 80 %
des apprentis qui trouve un job à
l'issue un cdi à l'issue de leur
formation donc un de 8 sur 10 ont un job
et c'est quand même un très beau score
donc là je vous propose de regarder une
petite vidéo sur la filière du goût
quand on dit goumondie restauration
boulangerie pâtisserie
la filière qui est proposé à la faculté
des métiers de l'essonne la faculté des
métiers de l'essonne c'est un outil de
formation
très important en ile-de-france qui a
que trois mille apprentis avec des
structures qui sont très modernes voilà
donc c'est un bel outil que l'on a en
essonne et voilà donc je vous invite à
regarder ce cette vidéo pendant deux
trois minutes
bienvenue dans le plus grand centre de
formation en alternance du sud
francilien la faculté des métiers de
l'essonne c'est 90 formations gratuites
et rémunérées du cp au bac + 5 dans huit
filières métiers répartis sur trois
sites
la faculté des métiers de l'essonne
accompagne chaque année 3000 apprentis
et cinq stagiaires de la formation
continue vers des parcours
professionnels réussi et de réelles
opportunités d'emploi en effet avec un
réseau de 2000 entreprises partenaires
elle affiche un taux d'insertion
professionnelle de plus de 80%
[Musique]
sur le site d'evry courcouronnes la
filière métiers du goût propose des
formations boulangerie pâtisserie
cuisine et service en restaurant
d'anciens apprentis aujourd'hui salarié
ou chefs d'entreprises et des apprentis
actuellement en formation témoignent de
leur expérience
mais pour ford la faculté des métiers ça
reste les professeurs et avec qui on
peut très vite bien s'entendre après bon
au niveau des locaux l'espace est très
pratique à utiliser ici à la faculté des
métiers on est très fier par nos profs
qui nous encadrent énormément ils nous
poussent ils sont là dans les mauvais
moments mais aussi dans les bon voilà on
s'amuse beaucoup et on travaille aussi
en même temps et le fait d'avoir aussi
des petites classes ça permet aux profs
d'être plus proche des élèves la faculté
des métiers on nous transmet la passion
et c'est ce qui fait que généralement on
s'en sort très bien aux examens à
l'apprentissage m'a apporté une maturité
déjà et ça m'a permis de prendre
confiance en moi et je ne peux et je
suis capable j'ai obtenu une médaille
d'argent au concours meilleurs apprentis
de france j'ai gagné le concours de la
meilleure baguette de tradition
2019 je pense que pour un patron qui est
prendre un jeune qui sans
d'apprentissage il va plus donné sa
confiance et on va être beaucoup plus
opérationnelles travaillent j'ai trouvé
du travail assez facilement avec une
formation pour apprentis ca fait en deux
ans bp en deux ans une formation
internationale ça m'a ouvert des portes
sur paris beaucoup de portes du coup
j'ai plus facilement rentrer dans les
restaurants qui sont difficiles d'accès
si on n'a pas de diplôme moi
personnellement je garde de très bons
souvenirs et j'espère le garder encore
longtemps contact avec nos formateurs
qui nous ont suivis moi sur mes cinq
années de formation tout s'est très bien
passé je regrette pas du tout dans cette
affaire je referais
si tu es deux pas de la gare rer est
organisée autour des espaces verts
arborés le campus d'evry de la faculté
des mythes et l'essonne propose des
équipements dédiés moderne et performant
deux amphithéâtres
un restaurant d'application ouvert au
public sur réservation un centre de
ressources
et un complexe sportif
deux espaces de restauration sont à
votre disposition
self et cafétérias enfin la faculté des
métiers de l'essonne dispose d'un
service d'accès à l'alternance proposant
notamment une prépa apprentissage et
permettant à la faculté des métiers
l'essonne d'être fiers d'intégrer tout
type de handicap alors n'hésitez pas
rejoignez nous
la rue
bonjour à tous donc je vais vous faire
un outil
focus sur les différents métiers des du
goût présent à la faculté des métiers
donc à savoir la boulangerie la
pâtisserie la cuisine le restaurant et
le talent reste donc on va commencer par
la boulangerie ou en sortie de troisième
vous pouvez rentrer chez nous on sait a
fait boule angers pour une formation de
deux ans d'accord à savoir deux ans de
formation
pour préparer un ca t1 boulanger ceci
après boulanger il est après
améliorable et au bout de deux ans vous
pouvez basculer directement sur un bp
boulangerie aussi en deux ans où vous
former à être dans un niveau 4 et à être
responsables de deux boutiques où
devront de boulanger était égal projet
professionnel merci après on est sûr
donc un petit peu ma partie le ca paix
pâtissier qui dure aussi deux ans donc à
toujours après la troisième j'insiste
c'est après la 3e ou 15 ans
sortie de sortie de collège voilà
cinquante 15 ans 31 décembre pour leurs
particularités
donc deux ans de pâtisserie vous pouvez
accéder en mention complémentaire sur la
pâtisserie glacerie chocolat cmcc
mention complémentaire et après basculer
comme alexis cas présent aujourd'hui
embêté à me pâtissier donc btm c'est
brevet technique des métiers de la
pâtisserie qui est un diplôme de chambre
des métiers qui nous accueille
aujourd'hui à evry donc c'est un diplôme
pas d'éducation nationale mais de
chambre des métiers voilà c'est la
spécificité sur ce métier
on a après les autres ça paie que de mes
collègues dont le capc hsrc les métiers
de vue service en salle le bac pro csr
c'est pareil c'est le bac pro en bacs en
en deux ans en trois ans par dont le
sait la paix en deux ans de restauration
en salle les titres pro à r ces agents
de restauration en deux ans
et nous avons après le ca ppsr donc ses
productions au service de restauration
en deux ans et nous avons après les seat
le ca fait cuisine en deux ans et inès
est aujourd'hui en saper cuisine et le
bac pro cuisine en trois ans donc ça
c'est la nouveauté de l'année dernière
pour tous qui essaient à terre après la
troisième et après vous avez pour
basculer on est pro et
et poursuivre vos études en cuisine le
bp qui est un brevet professionnel art
de la cuisine et le bac pro en cuisine
après un ca paix pour poursuivre ses
études et on a après un niveau d'étude
au dessus du bp qui est les bts sont que
de m&a chez harman c'est management en
hôtellerie restauration ou via une mise
à niveau avant pour acquérir le bts
ya ya une offre très importante à la
faculté des métiers concours choisissent
de faire plutôt boulangers pâtissiers ou
plutôt la cuisine des services au total
ça ça représente combien des mails sur
cette rentrée 2020 2022 dans cet
ensemble la de d'offres combien d'élèves
des métiers là où on a sur la fidélité
du go environ 500 apprentis minimum en
place et le chiffre évolue tout le temps
au long de l'année mais voilà on a à peu
près 500 apprentis en pâtisserie on a à
peu près
180 apprentis en pâtisserie à peu près
autant en boulangerie et le reste en
cuisine mais aussi une majorité de
boulanger pâtissier qui sortiront de
l'école avec un diplôme c'est apeu
bbtm à la clé tu vois que de btm on a il
n'y a pas de passerelle pour les mêmes
un bts ou
en tout cas est ce que ces feux
à faisable à faculté des métiers ce que
ça n'allait pas ailleurs c'est pas
faisable chez nous mais oui bien entendu
il ya les brevets de maîtrise qui
existent encore qui sont toujours là
donc toujours un diplômé chambre des
métiers encore le brevet de maîtrise et
on est sur un niveau supérieur de
demetris de pâtisserie qui existe aussi
en pâtisserie mais aux embouts l'enjeu
aussi également inès à têtu
voilà 41 ans et ap aujourd'hui quel a
été ton parcours auparavant quand on
commence à pourquoi terran aujourd'hui
on sait à peine est-ce que tu as un
parcours particulier par rapport à ce
qu'il nous a été présenté alors quand
j'étais en troisième oui la concerne
attention à ma proposé à ce que je dis
je voulais faire la cuisine oui un vrai
directement dit bob crow
donc j'étais en bac pro mais on
pratiquait pas assez en fait donc après
j'ai appris qu'on pouvait faire de
l'alternance donc je me suis figée vers
la faculté des métiers
et je suis parti sur un sap et ouais
mais en fait je ne savais pas du tout
que vous pouvez faire un bac pro en
alternance sinon j'aurais continué mon
bac pro en alternance
aujourd'hui tu es en première année où
des aînés la première année première
année est-ce que tu est satisfaite de
ton choix parce qu'il ya de la pratique
mais on apprend bien d'accord france
l'année prochaine deuxième année
et après qu'est ce qui se passe et après
est ce que tu as une projection est ce
que tu sais à peu près où tu vas trop
parce que je pense que je vais faire une
mention complémentaire
alors toi lexique et quel est ton
parcours par rapport à ce qu'on a vu la
slide qu'on a vu
quel a été ton chemin toi à partir de la
troisième ou la quatrième je sais pas
quel a été ton chemin
faisant
ouais mais après j'ai fait
le parti three en un an puis maintenant
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui changé diem en
première année sur deux ans
btm pâtisserie d'accord donc tu ne
comptes pas continuer dans la voie la
pâtisserie et donc la paix en cas
d'année pardon du trône dernier est ce
que tu sais ce que tu vas faire après
tomber tms que tu t'arrêtes quels sont
tes projets d'avenir
-
ouais en tant que salarié
d'accord
merci
donc bas dans notre fils un quiz a été
posée sur le chat la question est la
question est longue
l'apprentissage est réservée aux élèves
qui ne peuvent pas continuer des études
en enseignement général ou qui ne sont
pas motivés pour continuer les études
est ce vrai ou est ce faux la réponse
que vous avez donnée c'est faux et
évidemment faux
autant l'apprentissage a énormément
souffert d'une mauvaise image on pensait
que c'était une voie de garage il ya
quelques années autant aujourd'hui
l'apprentissage a retrouvé ses lettres
de noblesse et et elle est vraiment
adapté à un certain profil de jeunes
élèves qui n'ont pas la volonté n'ont
pas l'ambition ou même la capacité à
continuer des études générales qui au
contraire ont besoin parce que ça
correspond à leur personnalité à leur
histoire besoin de d'apprendre
rapidement à un métier ou même et
poursuivre des études dans un domaine
particulier qu'ils ont choisi et donc et
c'est faux et donc aujourd'hui
l'apprentissage a le vent en poupe
on note un depuis deux ans une évolution
importante du nombre d'inscriptions dans
les cfa
pour
faire de la formation en alternance et
donc par exemple si je vous donne un
exemple entre 2021 à rentrer 2021 et
celle de 2001 il ya eu 10 % de plus
d'inscrits alors c'est un chiffre
générique moyens il peut y en avoir
quinze de plus dans les filières du goût
et peut-être cinq dans le fil hier juste
pas de l'automobile prend effet tout à
l'heure mais en général c'est 10% de
plus
d'inscriptions ça veut dire que
l'apprentissage commence à vraiment
intéressé et que c'est important parce
que nous qui gérons à la chambre de
métiers des entreprises
il ya un certain nombre d'entreprises
qui vont être à céder dans les années à
venir et c'est important que le
renouvellement du tissu économique se
fasse naturellement elle se fait par le
biais justement de l'apprentissage et de
la formation des jeunes de la
transmission du savoir faire en
l'occurrence
si je vous ai rajouté aussi c'est
vraiment là particulier l'apprentissage
c'est l'immersion l'entreprise donc on
est là nous l'école pour former les
jeunes mais les les jeunes trop fort
mais aussi en entreprise par leur maître
d'apprentissage qui joue un rôle énorme
dans leur formation vous tuez l'inesss
par lesquels avaient fait un bac pro am
ont donc en initiale dans l'éducation
nationale et donc nous on est on est
reparti sur une formation en alternance
qui correspondent plus à son à son
souhait son profil mais voilà nous
toutes les formations sont en alternance
dont on est vraiment immergeant
d'entreprise au minimum deux jours par
semaine entreprises et les périodes de
vacances et tout au long de l'année vous
êtes au minimum plus à cette mode
entreprises dans l'année donc c'est
énorme et c'est ce que recherchent les
patrons derrière comme tu viens de me
dire qu'elle des jeunes qui sont
autonomes et qui sont le plus rapidement
accessible sur le marché du travail
c'est ça et donc je le rappelle on l'a
vu tout à l'heure c'est que
l'apprenti est un salarié d'entreprise
on est d'accord et qui dit salariés a
dit coutras et la vie justement
j'enchaîne
parce que cécile à trois conseils à nous
donner sur la manière dont on gère son
apprentissage côté jeunes donc ses fils
je vis à nous donner tes 3 3 conseils
pour pouvoir bien appréhender son
apprentissage bonjour à tous
bonjour à tous alors oui effectivement
donc je suis amené effectivement l'avoir
beaucoup de jeunes beaucoup beaucoup
d'employeurs et madame du bien annoncer
leurs membres dans la majorité des cas
sont pas très bien et dieu merci tout va
très très bien là effectivement des fois
il ya des petits ajustements à faire
surtout au début
au début de l'apprentissage parce que
mine de rien effectivement c'est pas
facile de se retrouver du jour au
lendemain
élèves et ensuite du jour au lendemain
salariés d'une entreprise c'est plus
facile à dire qu'à faire
et vous avez l'âge aussi que vous avez
et c'est tout à fait c'est tout à fait
normal
donc oui si j'avais trois conseil à vous
donner
on va dire pour bien enclenché son
apprentissage
en tout cas le bien bien débuté ça
serait ce parce que ces trois là donc en
petit 1 montrer sa motivation alors ça
effectivement ça ça paraît logique mais
effectivement ça englobe beaucoup de
choses la motivation se dira trailer
donc la concurrente est très importante
effectivement on l'a bien souligné
en contrat d'apprentissage vous serez
salariés donc payer effectivement donc
dans une entreprise on ne peut pas se
permettre de vous attendre cette partie
intégrante de l'entreprise et et d'une
équipe
donc c'est aussi montrer sa motivation
garder bien effet que vous faites à
l'école regardez bien
cette bonne habitude de
d'arrivée d'arriver à leur
montrer sa motivation ça veut dire quoi
aussi c'est peut-être
s'est également montré qu'on est de
bonne volonté si on a fini quelque chose
voilà demander s'il ya autre chose à
faire est ce qu'on l'a bien fait vous
avez tout à fait droite vous trompez ça
c'est tout pas vous êtes vous êtes là
pour ça mais effectivement
c'est une chose de tromper mais voilà
montrer sa motivation à part ça on s'en
est une autre
voilà la vague poudre lee effectivement
pas mal tout ça ça paraît très très
logique mais je pense qu'il faut le
rappeler et ça fonctionne toujours bien
d'un congé son apprentissage comme ça la
deuxième fois c'est de se passer de son
téléphone portable alors ça je le
soulignais je le redis si je pouvais
dans leurs souvenirs en rouge
c'est tout bête nous on est tous un peu
esclave aussi de notre téléphone
portable là je vous rassure mais vous
encore plus parce que vous êtes né avec
eux c'est votre troisième main et que
c'est encore plus compliqué
mais effectivement il va falloir
continuer à faire ces efforts là de bien
vous passer de votre téléphone portable
vous aurez effectivement dépose
au même titre qu'à l'école pour pour
pour
pour pouvoir récupérer votre téléphone
si je peux me permettre sur le téléphone
portable c'est vrai que c'est un très
bon outil pédagogique autant pour les
jeunes les vous les jeunes collégiens
que nous aussi mais pas en cours voilà
il y a des il ya des territoires ya des
heures par contre on sera sûrement amené
à travailler avec ont semblé tout ça
mais à des moments précis on rappelle
qu' il ya un examen passé à la fin de
cette formation et c'est pas tolérés le
téléphone en examen donc c'est vraiment
à repréciser et si je suis très content
qu'on en parle aujourd'hui
exactement là l'affection
tout à fait comme comme à l'épaule dans
l'entreprise c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui va falloir il va falloir faire
un effort là-dessus même si ça vous
coûte et j'en suis tout à fait tout à
fait consciente et voilà mais mais c'est
mais c'est très important parce que
effectivement quand vous avez votre
téléphone du coup vous n'êtes plus là
vous voilà vous êtes distrait tout ça
donc moi ce que je vous invite à faire
c'est effectivement faire attention
extrêmement attention à ça à l'école et
en entreprise parce qu'effectivement
l'employeur s'il vous voit effectivement
votre portable il va peut-être le
laisser passer une fois mais ça va te
fait lagacé et puis une deuxième fois sa
voir ça comme il vous a rien dit vous
allez le refaire et l'institut d'études
voilà on arrive après à des conflits qui
sont tous bêtes et finalement qui
peuvent être évitées donc vraiment de
faire attention à ça et de toute façon
vous allez encore une fois vous avez des
pauses pour pouvoir le récupérer et puis
j'aurai plein de messages et ça sera
très satisfaisant pour vous
donc ensuite j'ai le troisième coincé
solliciter des échanges avec le maître
d'apprentissage alors ça j'aime explique
un petit peu
c'est surtout par rapport à mon vécu
effectivement et des conflits qui
peuvent qu ils peuvent y avoir en main
en entreprise
n'hésitez pas dès le début effectivement
dont enclenché cette habitude
d'avoir cinq petites minutes alors les
cfa tous les cfa ne fonctionne pas
pareil mais souvent c'est une semaine
d'école une semaine une semaine
entreprises ou deux semaines l'école de
semaine l'entreprise compte c'est la fin
de la semaine de votre entreprise je
vous invite de prendre juste cinq
minutes pas très longtemps vraiment
vraiment il n'y a pas besoin de ce soit
très long pour échanger avec votre votre
bête d'apprentissage pour savoir un
petit peu pour vous ôter auto évaluer
avec lui en lui disant bah voilà qu
est-ce qui bat qu'est-ce qu'il va pas
qu'est ce que je dois améliorer
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce que je dois
faire pour persévérer parce que je suis
bon dans quelque chose en particulier
enfin voila je trouve que c'est plutôt
pas mal vous allez créer du coup une
proximité avec votre maître
d'apprentissage un dialogue et un
échange qui est primordial pour que
votre apprentissage fonctionne parce que
effectivement beaucoup de conflits
ont peuvent arriver
par manque de communication tout
simplement parce que logan
d'apprentissage c'est pas parce qu'ils
le passé juste parce qu'il n'a pas le
temps parce qu'il est pris tout ça
surtout dans l'infection dans la
restauration le temps est compté et ça
s'entend mais effectivement même si ses
cinq petites minutes surtout
voilà il faut il faut il faut il
instaurer dès le début et si
effectivement
ça ne se fait pas et que le médecin
quand d'apprentissage vous ne fait pas
de lui-même n'hésitez pas à le
solliciter pour prendre ses cinq petites
ne se passera jamais mal perçu et ça
sera bien au contraire voilà ça sera
gagné la fuite pour vous merci
voilà l
envie de poser la question à inès et
alexis est ce que vous complétez riez le
propos de cécile qui quand même une
expérience intéressante en matière de
relation entre le maître d'apprentissage
et d'apprentis
qu'est-ce que vous donneriez de plus
comme conseils aux apprentis peut-être
aux élèves qui vont devenir apprenti
ainsi vous aviez un conseil à donner ce
serait lequel
les changes les changes échangé avec son
maître d'apprentissage
ça permet de quoi ça permet peut-être de
s'auto-évaluer de s'autocritiquer de
voir si on fait bien j'ai envie de dire
mais ça ça sape dans la vie de tous les
jours ça s'applique aussi en classe là
en ce moment vous êtes élève de 3e 4e ça
s'applique et toi est-ce que tu
compléterait par autre chose en dehors
des changes
savoir qu'est ce qu'ils pensent de nous
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait prendre en
amélior oui
d'accord merci avec oui comment comment
s'améliorer comment se recadrer comment
essayer de se perfectionner
ok merci avec 6 et inès je propose qu'on
qu'on déroule la suite
voilà
une procédure d'inscription alors si
jamais vous les gars j'ai déjà demandé
j'en ai partout maintenant n'hésitez pas
à venir vous auriez à petit je suis un
peu juste après cette slide donc comment
faire donc déjà vous inscrire sur notre
site sur le site fakfak métier qu'à
trois point fr donc on verrait la page
d'accueil du raf l'hippodrome où se
seraient mortes et se préinscrire
surtout inscrivez-vous bien le fait pas
de faute sur votre nom prénom numéro de
téléphone mail et puis surtout un cv
parce que si jamais vous inscrire mais
capable chez les dames moi je préfère
vous accompagner pour trouver une
entreprise
dont je complétais dire votre dossier cv
inscrits mais vraiment faim indiqué
vraiment j'en rajoutais pas vraiment
tous les documents demandés parce que si
vous ne faites pas des départs
pourquoi le faire maintenant respect
c'est aujourd'hui face à partir de
demain j'aurai plein de demandes
d'entreprises et souza se fait
maintenant face à motiver et je vais pas
vous mentir c'est quasiment leur premier
arrivé premier servi sa tension de la
motivation vraiment la motivation et le
professionnel c'est ça va de pair
donc dès que vous êtes inscrit votre
erreur d'entretien soit dorée à l'or à
l'entretien soit collectif en tout cas
sûre en individuel
tout au long
de votre recherche
je vous raconte pas une je suis pas là
scénario c'est des formateurs
aussi énormément votre réseau surtout
qu'il ya
quelqu'un donc le réseau c'est important
prêt préparez vous soyez les vrais pros
fait des petits entretiens en sachant
que noël affecter des métiers on a la
possibilité de vous inscrire si vous
souhaitez à dte c'est à dire c'est des
ateliers de techniques de recherche
d'emploi on en reprend faire des cv et
des lettres de motivation vous présentez
prospecter
également chose à laquelle on n'a pas
parlé
avec les dix métiers on a également une
chargée de mission handicap si jamais
vous êtes en situation d'handicap mais
c'était surtout pas les lavoirs parce
que parce que nous ça nous aidera aussi
à mieux
vous proposer des entreprises même si
vous n'êtes pas dans l'obligation légale
de le dire en tout cas ne vous cachez
pas ça
donc voilà inscrivez vous faites un beau
cv lettre de motivation et faxer fait de
toute façon on vantait alors je note je
note que
finalement le
la complexité si on peut appeler ça une
complexité dans le parcours de
l'apprentissage c'est peut-être de
trouver son employeur qui va vous
accueillir pendant un an deux ans c'est
peut-être ça la complexité quand comment
toi tu as fait alexis commenta procédé
pâtisserie puis quand je me suis
présenté pour le stage de 3e j'ai dit ce
que je voulais faire après de fer
pâtisserie puis après ça il veut dire
maintenant c'est vrai dire oui et
pour ce qui concerne ça a été un oui ou
par non pas avec cette pâtisserie là un
accord
alors j'ai pris plusieurs entreprises
bientôt on voit la faculté à deux mois
d'un bas débit et puis bah en fait des
demandes toutes les informations on a
pris part aux portes quelques bâtisses
qui en a fait
voir notre lettre de motivation dans
tout ça c'est qu'on a bien avec qui sait
ça c'est normal avec dj où on va les
voir
faire l'atelier ouais donc il ya un
accompagnement de la faculté des métiers
pour trouver un employeur il t'a fait du
combien de temps toi pour trouver un ton
employeur qui est aujourd'hui une
pâtisserie boulangerie pâtisserie ou
pâtisseries tout court
pâtisserie
d'accord parce que tu étais bien préparé
pour le coup
le réseau ton réseau d'accords hockey et
et toi de queen s comment
c était en
juillet dernier ouais après le mon bac
pro bas
j'ai décidé de pas quand j'étais déjà
les j'ai vu sur le site que madeco va
devoir d'employeur bas on pouvait venir
du coup le lendemain j'ai regardé des
restaurants a officiellement j'ai appelé
les restaurants pour demander s'ils
prenaient des apprentis et m'ont dit cui
juste de déposer une motivation et un cv
et dans la journée j'ai presque trop de
chats et demander le contre est
directement waouh soit tu fais un jour
ça tu fais partie de ces gens j'ai une
question si un jeune veut
faire une alternance mais dans une
entreprise étrangère ou alors on va
parler de l'europe pour le moment est ce
possible ça
pour certaines formations c'est possible
par exemple c'est possible chez nous et
à l'étranger mais en tout cas s'ils
veulent aller à l'étranger après la
formation au contraire amitié comme
disait tout à l'heure qui est tout à
fait
conseillé oui voilà à l'étranger sont
très demandés pour exporter le savoir
faire mais là en l'occurrence on ne peut
pas avoir un
une entreprise
après c'est vrai que là on était bloqués
pendant deux ans pour les projets
circulation à l'étranger mais il existe
toujours parcourir asmus que certains
jeunes peuvent aussi profiter et bien
entendu est hélas les les voyagistes et
on commence à reprendre contact avec nos
partenaires étrangers pour faire des
séjours en immersion dans les
entreprises dans les pays différents
européen voilà quelques capacités il
faut inès pour faire de l'apprentissage
dans la finir la section table
choisissez des
capacités
et ans pour faire parce que j'imagine sa
promise pas cuisinier
mais pas qu'est-ce qui a fait que
c'était la cuisine en bas la passion
c'est de la passerelle fret passionnés
de cuisine parce que si on n'a pas déjà
et une passion aussi si on apprend la
patience de fonds accuse de vue
cuisinier bas on n'arrivera jamais
patience de la passion parce que c'est
surtout un match est bon pour ma part où
j'ai toujours été avec des hommes déjà
parce que quand j'étais en bac pro
j'étais la seule fille d'accord de ma
classe est bon là ça va on est deux fils
et des filles dans la douleur mais c'est
surtout un match et où en est on avec
des hommes et il accuse aussi recevoir
des ordres du combat il faut savoir
recevoir des ordres et donc il faut
accepter d'être dirigé d'être managé et
de faire ce qu'on me demande de faire
dans un temps il est calculé d'où la
patience du tout ça dis donc
de ton côté toi qui a choisi la
pâtisserie cas quelles sont les qualités
d'un jeune apprenti en pâtisserie
c'est la même chose que c'est la volonté
la passion parce que c'est pas un métier
facile non plus oui mais vraiment la
passion parce que pour le vouloir parce
que c'est pas un métier que
je ne veux pas faire toi
vas par ici
d'accord
ça veut dire que tu faisais des
croissants ou du pain ou des gâteaux
très tôt dans sa jeunesse en famille
tu as toujours voulu faire ça ok donc
c'est quand donc j'étais pas trompé de
chemin brio
ok alors il nous reste 15 minutes
il ya encore un slide voilà de
présentation des jpo alors stéphanie
qui a persisté et ensuite on savait le
12 mars le va former et je fasse un
choix ils ont également les maires de
france et celles qui ont déjà débuté
elle
voulait nous rencontrer les laboratoires
sont ouverts vous venez allant discuter
avec les apprentis avec les formateurs
directement dans les laboratoires en
cuisine ou en pâtisserie ou en
boulangerie et venir voir comment ils
travaillent en entreprise et comment ça
se passe donc samedi à la chante en les
restrictions sont apaisées
on va pouvoir enfin voir des
démonstrations
peut-être goûté on verra mais en tout
cas se rencontrent des réalisations des
élèves qui sont en pâtisserie de sa
cuisine et des magnifiques choses qui
sont faites pas ce que vient un moment
donné on la limite entre l'art et
l'artisanat
elle est pas loin mais on voit dans les
sections boulangerie pâtisserie cuisine
quasiment d audard et je tiens à saluer
et c'est pas pour rien que aujourd'hui
des émissions comme meilleur pâtissier
mais en boulanger meilleur achat un
succès fou parce qu'on voit à quel point
la richesse des deux ce qui est fabriqué
proposés et tout ça c'est grâce au
professeur qui donne les bases mais
après c'est au ces la personnalité c'est
tout ce qui fait le
lan vie du jeune pour réaliser d'autres
choses et donc c'est le moment ou jamais
de d'assister aux portes ouvertes
j'insiste là dessus 5 février à la la
c'est toutes les filières qui ouvriront
ainsi donc c'est un choix incroyable
tomobile vous vous
le service un bon dossier le moment là
trois mille étudiants là bas donc c'est
le moment d'aller voir un petit peu des
sensibilités et donc voilà je vous
invite vraiment à vous déplacer aller
profiter
le faire
donc voilà je te laisse se faire des
contacts et ensuite nous passerons à vos
questions alors pour les contacts donc
vous inscrire en boulangerie pâtisserie
si jamais vous avez des questions
n'hésitez pas à envoyer un mail à bout
le pointage @ fm 91 point fr pour tout
ce qui est cuisiné une restauration
titre propre fsr vous pouvez contacter
madame moore a donc effectivement la
tournelle mais également son aliment
téléphone n'hésitait pas à l'appeler moi
donc je suis là et mes coordonnées mon
numéro de téléphone portable et on
adresse mail donc moi c'est vraiment
dans l'accompagnement à la recherche
d'entreprises et pour toutes questions
qui sont pas une femme différente de
l'inscription ou la recherche entreprise
vous avez notre responsable adam faut
également si jamais vous avez des
questions à poser aux formateurs
n'hésitez pas à passer par moi et je
transmettrai merci beaucoup
alors la première question
mais yat-il d'élèves par classe alors
les classes entières 28 maximum en
classe entière il faut savoir qu en
atelier la classe est divisé en deux
donc ils sont au maximum 14 en pratique
voilà j'ai bien dit maximum 14 ans
pratiquent donc
en un tour par personne pour pour
évoluer son tout le matériel nécessaire
pour évoluer pour réaliser la production
en pratique mais en classe entière 28
maximum
et sur les sections parlons niveau
supérieur on est sur des effectifs
beaucoup plus réduit puisqu'on est en
qualité beaucoup plus
bas ont beaucoup plus grosse et et voilà
faut faut affiner les sélections et les
et le niveau aussi
alors comment une personne n'ayant pas
été scolarisés jusqu'en 3e au collège
peut intégrer la filière quelle que soit
la filière quelle que soit ma tisserie
boulangerie ou cuisine
à l'élève lorsque latin une personne
n'ose quelle année comment il fait
alors autrefois on avait des d'imams
mais ça n'existe plus nous ça nous
permet d'accueillir des gens qui avaient
deux mois - 14 ans qui n'avait pas
tellement troisième là aujourd'hui si
vous avez 15 ans et 15 ans le 31
décembre de l'année en cours vous pouvez
faire de l'apprentissage à partir de 15
ans
après au delà blasé source sous
condition de stage mais des vo 15 ans
exactement le même statut qu'un apprenti
qu'un salarié en entreprise il faut
avoir 30 ans ça c'est important et si
vous venez joindre à combien de journées
portes ouvertes explique
ça veut dire qu'un élève qui a arrêté en
quatrième admettons est-ce que ça se
fait ça je ne sais rien est ce qu'il
peut faire de l'apprentissage il n'a pas
fait sa 3e
31 et ce quel que soit le niveau
scolaire 31 ans najib harcourt
d'inscription pour en sortant un
collégien sorti 3e d'accord voilà il va
s'inscrire sur le site chez nous pour
inscription et à mon frangin
alors quels sont les critères de
sélection des élèves pour intégrer
laisser happer de la filière du goût
alors quelle que soit boulangerie
cuisine quels sont les critères de
sélection il n'y a pas de critères de
sélection les critères de sélection
c'est l'envi voilà c'est ça c'est l'envi
c'est sait on va dire aussi plus vite
vous trouverez une entreprise et plus
vite vous pourrez intégrer aussi la
faculté des métiers et tous les métiers
de l'alternance donc
allez-y maintenant franchement c'est le
temps idéal pour rechercher une
entreprise
n'attendez pas nous entendre des mets
pas au collège aller chercher des
entreprises aller démarcher les
entreprises des patrons pour pour pour
obtenir un contrat d'apprentissage
rapidement et fait des stages aussi en
entreprise c'est très important
l'immersion d'entreprise allez voir
comment ça se passe
ce qu'a dit sandrine au niveau de la
télé c'est bien mais ça reste de la télé
oui donc il faut aller voir on est des
métiers de l'artisanat il faut aller
voir comment ça se passe c'est important
alors y at il une formation spécifique à
la faculté des métiers pour être serveur
en restaurant
effectivement dont nous avons la
commercialisation et service en
restauration donc c'est une formation
alors si c'est le capc formation deux
ans c'est au sortir du collège avec une
alternance alors si je me trompe pas
deux jours c'est pas trois jours
l'entreprise donc ce qui montre bien que
vous êtes vraiment plus en entreprise
donc à cette formation sur deux ans ou
alors le bac pro qui est sur trois ans
sauf si vous avez déjà capc sera sur un
an et celles à l'alternance est une
semaine l'entreprise une semaine cfa et
donc pour ces formations tout à fait
venez donc samedi on vous expliquera
toutes les subtilités et ce sont des
belles formations et je vais pas vous
mentir des serveurs disparaissent donc
si vous voulez faire ce métier vous êtes
toutes les chances pour vraiment évolué
et trouver une entreprise si
effectivement la motivation est là oui
il ya une pénurie de main d'oeuvre dans
la région rations et les dernières
mesures ou évoqué l'augmentation des
salaires les patrons ont bien conscience
que les conditions sont compliquées donc
beaucoup d'améliorations et et donc il
ya un vrai marché apprendre de votre
côté pour être serveur et et
d'ajouter je vais ajouter je répondre à
la question
donc dès qu un élève à un patron il est
peut être s'inscrire au cfa bien entendu
les les inscriptions sont ouvertes sur
le site très prochainement et là venez
nous rencontrer et des cadres un patron
et bloquent la place elle est tranquille
pour l'année prochaine et sécuriser son
parcours de formation et peut
tranquillement finir sont ces années au
collège et fait passer son brevet des
collèges tranquillement et sereinement
pour l'année prochaine d'accord mais
c'est pas la condition bière on peut
s'inscrire à la faculté des métiers sans
forcément tout de suite avoir de patron
on a un petit d'airé pour en trouver
mais l'idéal franchement c'est quand
même de la voir avant
l'inscription au pire on va de septembre
comme ça on est soulagé on attaque sa
formation dans les conditions plus
sereines
une autre question
alors les personnes de plus de 30 ans
peuvent elles s'inscrire
pour une formation en alternance alors
une formation à la en alternance oui
parce que formation en alternance
contrats d'apprentissage ou le contrat
de professionnalisation
comme je disais tout à l'heure quand et
plus de 29 ans vous pouvez être apprenti
sous certaines conditions avoir un
statut d'handicapé reconversion
professionnelle ou être sportif de haut
niveau après ces deux contrats de
professionnalisation et là il faut voir
si c'est une reconversion pouvoir
approcher les vols emploi ou d'un
financement voilà après la tessoualle
est trop longue enfin la réponse est
trop longue pour visionner comme ça mais
cette possibilité là effectivement et
est-ce que c'est limité dans l'âge alors
le contrat de professionnalisation dans
ce cas différents contrats après
l'alternance en plus si on répond trois
conditions énoncées tout à l'heure il
n'y a pas apprentissage il n'y a pas de
limite dan alors si cantat à petit c'est
jusqu'à voir d'avoir évolué d'un camp de
casques d'appartements est moche après
il ya des conditions qui nous permet
d'aller au-delà d'accord sous certaines
conditions soient approfondis revisser
des projets d'accord donc
alors
peut-on revoir peut tout il reste 5
minutes ok peut-on revoir les
coordonnées des différents
interlocuteurs
les voici à l'écran mais comme je le
disais tout à l'heure
tout sera sur le site de la chambre de
métiers et puis tout est sur le site
aussi de la faculté des métiers
ce replay sera diffusée largement
sur nos médias et ce certainement de la
faculté des métiers de nos autres
partenaires donc vous retrouver bon ben
je pense que vous avez eu le temps de
faire la photo y at il d'autres
questions sur le tchat
non pas pour le moment je vous laisse
réfléchir un peu
à
est-ce qu'il faut déjà des connaissances
de base des pré requis pour intégrer une
formation en apprentissage quel que soit
le niveau quoi je veux répondre alors
nicolas donc non pas spécialement les
prérequis les les connaissances de base
ça va être l'envi la motivation de vous
les collégiens qui ont envie d'apprendre
le métier voilà vous allez directement
acquérir des connaissances de base des
prérequis en faisant des gâteaux avait
chez vous dans vos familles en allant
vous intéresser avec une chaîne youtube
avec un tweeter avec what's app ou autre
chose et échanger avec des copains et
des copines ou des réseaux sociaux c'est
les prérequis il y en a pas besoin si
vous en avez tant mieux c'est mieux pour
nous mais derrière nous on forme des
apprentis qui n'ont peu ou jamais fait
pâtisserie ou de cuisine ou de services
voilà où deux boulangeries sait on pas
tout le monde arrive avec un niveau et
on est là pour vous former être le plus
près des entreprises et au ca paix et à
la suite de de vos études oui parce que
vous en faites les prérequis mme même
s'il y en a même si un élève à a
beaucoup cuisiner dans sa danse à
claquettes de ses parents vous repartez
voilà avant de passer sur les bases et
c'est tout de même niveau et les progrès
qui j'ai envie de dire on les efface
ses et vous repartez tout le monde vous
former tout le monde au même niveau et
avec les mêmes les mêmes techniques
c'est ça c'est ça on a tous un des
univers différents métiers différentes
personnes et fait rage donc on où il
reprend toutes les bases pour tout le
monde puisque c'est les diplômes qui est
conforme à la fin et qui sont certifiés
avec le même niveau pour tout le monde
et la rigueur ouais je voulais rajouter
tout à l'heure c'est à ce moment là la
rigueur qu'on doit avoir pour tous ces
métiers d'alimentaire particulièrement
voilà c'est très important à voir mais
dans tout ce que vous ferez plus tard
après le collège et déjà maintenant avec
le brevet bientôt c'est la rigueur dans
le travail dans les études et c est
votre parcours professionnel très
important une autre question alors il ya
j'imagine dans le c ap le btm enfin bref
le bep
ya des ya des matières qui sont des
matières techniques carlier à
métier appris mais quel pourcentage de
matières dites général
anglais français
je vais répondre aussi donc on est selon
les niveaux d'étude ils sont au minimum
une journée dans la semaine en travaux
pratiques en atelier donc un maximum 14
en cours donc un atelier tous les 15
jours selon niveau d'études voilà ça
c'est pour laisser happer après l'essai
la paix en un an ils ont deux jours de
pratique tous les quinze jours voilà
comme les vtm alexis est là et les
niveaux supérieurs et à côté ils ont
deux à trois jours d'enseignement
général maximum il son maximum quatre
jours par semaine en cours au lieu des
cinq jours au collège p4 je remets alors
alors dansez dansez s'étend de matières
générales
enfin deux d'enseignement sans pratique
qu'elle est à peu près le pourcentage de
deux des matières dites générales ces
français et anglais c'est 30 à 40 % le
reste ceux des matières professionnelles
qui passeront un examen j'assiste comme
le collège et votre brevet cette année
toutes les matières que vous fait vous
allez passer un diplôme donc forcément
il faudra travailler pour les avoir pour
avoir le brevet pour avoir le c à payer
toutes les matières vous serez obligé de
dépasser c'est un diplôme et donc
forcément faut valider des matières et
puis ces matières
dites générales servent dans l'exercice
du
lin boulangers pâtissiers ben ya un peu
de chimie dedans dans la cuisine aussi
mais il ya un peu de mathématiques du
dosage
c'est bien sûr sous les matières sont
importantes tu as dit ma pour les
calculs fois de l'erreur cette fois de
plus 2 - 2 / 3 par carette on a quinze
couverts qu'est ce qu'on va faire on a
30 coûte ouvert qu'est ce qu'on doit
faire c'est très important mais c'est
des matières qui sont appliquées aux
victimes notre webinaire se termine on
est dans les temps on vous remercie
énormément de votre attention des
questions vous avez pu poser on espère
vous avoir fourni le maximum
d'informations en une heure et on vous
invite surtout à faire plein de vidéos
plein de journées portes ouvertes à très
bientôt et bon courage et bonne
continuation à bientôt et merci
[Musique]